there's no shortage of problems facing
africa's governments
unemployment drought famine ebola and
now the rise in violent extremism
the head of the african union says the
continent needs to act together to face
the challenge posed by extremist groups
in particular the brutality of bokoram
against our people
the senseless killings the destruction
of property the enslavement and
sale of our people especially girls
are a threat to our collective safety
security and development
attacks by boko haram in northern
nigeria have reached
new levels over the past few weeks zuma
says
boko haram is now no longer just a
nigerian problem
the african union's peace and security
council is calling for a regional force
of seven and a half thousand troops to
fight the militants
the un secretary general ban ki-moon
welcomed the effort and
offered his support as the percentage of
terrorism knows
no boundaries and affects african
countries
in the horn the sahel and
elsewhere which informed our the african
union is hoping that the un will provide
the money for the military offensive
against boko haram